it is time
to play
expedition zero when my team reached out
to me and asked
if i wanted to play a survival horror
game uh this video is sponsored by
expedition zero expedition zero
naturally i said yes uh it's my favorite
genre of video game and i don't know
what we're in for i did not look into it
super hard i will play virtually any
horror game ever so that's what we're
doing ready to get real spooked very big
uh thank you to expedition zero for
sponsoring
the
stream slash video today the game is out
now on steam gog and the epic store for
19.99
i'll leave a link in the description if
you want to check it out okay
let's go
save one seems fine yeah
um
i'm expecting this game to be hard
i will say that
i shouldn't have come here but
i needed to see
he just forgot about me
left me here to rot
hmm
i need to get out oh okay
okay i'm gonna need to move my
camera start here
so that
we can show both of these bars
maybe if i go like here
just to make sure everybody can see
everything that seems right
image
come over here that seems good
let me know if i'm cutting anything off
okay
[Music]
this is a map
[Music]
that's where i am
that looks like a rocket can i go to
rocket
okay
oh maybe that's fast travel
what what even is this
hmm
battery connect charger i don't think i
have one storage open storage
we got some health pills
and we will take them
needs power to open okay i need power
is that gonna
uh
i'm gonna have to plug that into
something there let's take that okay
unclear
where
it's a cool
setup love a video game that lets you
jump that has to go the whole way over
here huh
fuel
add fuel uh
okay i think we've done that
now can i open the door
no
hmm
try this again
surely this won't go i didn't i didn't
think that would work to be clear
did i turn the generator on
no i just tried to okay i need to figure
out how to add fuel is it called e
no
pick up
uh okay
i feel like it should tell me how to
actually use it
[Music]
what do i have to do like inventory
stuff i do have two of them
how do i quick access we can put you at
one
no
health pills should go down there
can't okay
uh
aim your weapon
hold aha
and then it's gonna
be add fuel
reload your weapon i do not have a
weapon but thank you
um
where do i put it
extra close prompt
well i'm holding it
no no that's still just trying to turn
it on
is that
maybe i have to be more specific about
placement like here
it's got to do something
oh you're right the scroll wheel i
thought that was just a menu
uh now
aha
it did not occur to me that i could
scroll there that's interesting i'm not
used to seeing that that's neat
okay
and then we just turn it on
[Music]
i look like i'm dressed like a spaceman
all right
did i just say that
i'm only scared of that because i know
that this is a survival horror and not
because it's actually scary
face to
okay
i'm also not used to a survival horror
game starting with its light out
um
is there anything else in here
set respawn point that seems handy
i'm gonna use it i guess
[ __ ] are you talking about josh what on
earth is that comment
um okay that seems bad
i do not have one
noted okay
um
whoa
oh
not sure if i was supposed to do that
but
guess we're going to a wall now
it's crouching time
yeah i guess i just i'm well i want to
see what happens if i try to run into
the woods
i recognize that i'm not supposed to
but consider this
[ __ ] around and find out
this is invisible wall okay yeah you
just can't
interesting approach
is the idiots in a broad podcast not
gonna release on youtube this month just
asking because of rahul tweet some days
ago um also thank you stormlight um no
you will get an extra episode on patreon
uh so the episode that is not
being released we had to record two
basically so the episode that is not
being released is only going on patreon
uh which is what
his tweet is referring to
and then there will be a regular public
episode but there will be a special
episode
given to patreon supporters that is not
going to be public
yeah we basically had to re-record
um all right
i'm just assuming that i should be
avoiding the spotlights
which doesn't feel easy
hmm
i made out more samples
serious man contact me by a rating on
promise i need to meet him in person but
it must be helpful so that will help me
get there
okay yeah so i need to oh
oh
what
is causing the heartbeat is it when the
lights are close to being on me or
someone's close to seeing me maybe is
there somebody in this
oh hut
doesn't look like it
um okay
i need to get to a radio by the sounds
of things
hello timberhawk welcome
okay
uh game already released yes
this game is available right now
on gog
and
steam
and the epic store all right
[Music]
took a risk there that was harder than i
expected okay
uh we will do the quick save
at least now i know that i insta die
gotta keep that in mind
uh it's not on xbox game pass i think
the game's only on pc actually
all right we will get shot in the face
if the spotlight see us it make like i
expected as much but i also vaguely
thought i was in the clear so i was like
i'll be fine
it was not fine
that's not gonna be fine either
these oh
spotlight controllers are actually doing
a very good job of of uh
appearing to be random i know they
aren't but they look it they're pretty
close
you ever see the moma meme did i find it
scary or serving i have seen momo um
no
i
had no real opinion on it if i'm being
honest
no strong thoughts taking a risk taking
a risk taking a risk
i think i'm okay
[Music]
oh
i wasn't sure if they could see me okay
that's tough
all right
give it another shot
um
i was gonna say maybe it's smarter to
run but i doubt it
i'm just trying to get to her radio
right
really trying not to be shot in the head
[Music]
okay
i think from here i have like a bit of a
clear shot for a second and then crouch
right i'm good
i think the snipe is uh
next to the lights
all right i got shot over there
i don't feel good about this
i feel like i'm gonna
and then run over there maybe
[ __ ]
i'm just gonna wait till this one's over
and then run
okay
i am now out of our line of sight
but where to go from here
maybe i should be interacting with that
crank
but how would i like it could also not
be interacted well no i think i gotta
get inside
gotta find this man on the radio
i don't really want to walk directly in
front of the light you know
damn okay
i should just i should just do it just
to see if i get shot because in theory
nobody's here you know what i'm saying
i'm gonna do it we're probably gonna get
shot
and we did not okay
did get sort of stuck though
[Music]
go go go go go go go okay
we made it
there's nobody here okay
i mean this appears to be closed
i really think that would open um
this is very dark
i can't see very much
this way
hello good you found me
cool you're still alive you are not as
useless as the ones i've met before
so let me award you for your efforts
a key card for the locked room in the
house you came from
thank you
so you want to get out there are some
ways but well let's say they don't come
for free
let's make a deal something has been
going on in the motley forest you know
that place
whatever is roaming in the forest it was
strong enough to kill all of the
soldiers that are out there i will be
helping you in identifying the source
but i need samples
find something that could be traced to
death
thing
don't forget to get yourself a
flashlight back at your place it gets
really dark out okay
yeah got it okay
i think this game is going to be really
hard
um can i just travel back now
and try not to die i'm trying man
not feeling very supported by you right
oh they stopped
oh that's nice okay let's go
they conveniently took a nap whoa thank
you go skill thank you for the five
gifted subs my friend
nice to see you
thank you so much
subs right now
uh going to
ukraine
all right back
to the house
uh which is shelter
get flashlight go forest
got it
okay
my own noises keep scaring me
don't mind me
oh this is bigger than i expected
pry ball
a gun
don't mind no space for item
bro come on now i guess it's too big for
me
i can't search anything without the pry
bar
printer but using the 3d printer you can
make useful upgrades
and items he's have to craft an item you
need metal wow okay there's like full
crafting in this that's cool
i'm unreasonably fearful of this cabin
private
i will take it
and a glowing note
warning to all personnel the new
analyzer equipment that we have recently
received has detected a significant
amount of organic spores in the outside
air
the tests indicate that the spores
although relatively harmless could lead
a person to experience shortness of
breath and hallucinations
in order to minimize productivity losses
and limit unnecessary exposure
the following orders are implemented
all personnel of access level 03 and
above as well as visitors are required
to wear bps9 gas masks while outside
personnel below access level 0 3 are
required to take one tablet of retizen
every two hours being outside
the orders are effective immediately you
can receive necessary items at the
storehouse is that where i am
am i storehouse is storehouse me
don't know ooh
cool trumpet
cool
axe no trumpet guy is cooler even though
his face is literally
he's much cooler
i think i did a great job of doing his
face um okay pryba
oh there's a whole slot for it but i
want you down here so i can use you very
easily
i can put you in both
my man
all right
it's time
to get priyan
maybe i'm just supposed to open this
without the private
i would like to open it
nothing
oh you got some screws okay
take all items
oh the inventory is so small though
but if i need that for crafting
hmm
hmm
generic controller
huh that's it we out of
space for things
okay
um
and i can't like move this stuff around
any storage
okay let's see if i can craft something
with the things i have
no
hmm
it's such a small inventory there's got
to be a way to level it up
storage
aha
metal
wires
okay
cool
i already did those two right yeah
trash bin
who put a candle holder in there
come on so i still don't seem to be able
to pick it up that i'm gonna need to
upgrade my inventory that's what it is
i just don't know how to do that yet
okay
thank you poopa boy thanks so much
um do we have anything else that we can
[Music]
break
no sir
no sir
well i don't want to be the blame not
anymore it's your turn
take a seat hey
i didn't even consider that getting rid
of the jerry can
average size backpack did that increase
my space i'm not sure if it did
but maybe if i get rid of the jerry can
i can get the gun
with gaming now
and the capacitor can go in here too
take a seat i'm settling
the final score
so did the backpack make my
equip
oh
i just didn't have it equipped
okay
and i'm still thinking breakdown
resources
um blueprints we only have headlight
module
which i can't make yet because i need
or i did just craft it
i like module crafted items headlight
one
no i think i'm missing something
polymer plastics metal electro
components i need more
polymer plastics and metal
metal
um
insufficient items yeah i just need more
stuff but like that's that's two metal
oh it's up here
okay this is
metal and polymer plastics
we're pretty
close that's just metal let's just put
them all in here
just need oh no it's good it's good to
go
okay cool
head round
would that be by no that would be head
mount
um
okay
by default to toggle the headlight is
wheel
haha
this is cool i'm enjoying the
tutorialization going on here having a
good time
okay
i kind of want to explore a little bit
more because i feel like i'm safe out
here nobody's going to shoot me in the
face
brief moments of safety before
whatever it is that's supposedly in that
forest shows up and ruins my life
or rather i show up to it
okay this all looks quite nice
i wish that's how 3d printing worked
yeah
i mean someone could shoot me
even here
pry
ball fine i'll be back here later i'm
sure
i didn't
there we go
uh maybe i already did that
no it's my health pills one
okay three
we have a gun now baby
don't know that i'm gonna use it though
um okay let's go to the forest i guess
my backpack which is my inventory takes
place up in my inventory yes but look at
this
it's already equipped um
it is the reason the inventory is so big
so it gave me way more space i guess
it's letting me know that i have an
average sized backpack currently that's
the way it's like kept the ui simple as
my thought
uh interact yes okay we're going to the
forest
oh no
i'm very scared
the game does watch twitch to see user
interaction i think they do
i've had plenty of devs in in chat
okay
so
find samples
oh there's a whole map here this could
be big
um
i'm assuming i can't go this way but i
like to explore
all right fine i recognize you're
telling me i'm gonna die
i see it i see it i see it
what is the
the
battery thing on the bottom right trying
to tell me i want to
i know i made myself real cold
doing what i just did but i can't help
myself my curiosity
oh my health went down that whole time
oh i see okay
i mean those guys at the last level one
hit killed me
anyway so
i don't know that i need that much
health
okay
excellent i will take all of those thank
you
i appreciate that
hello
hmm
okay
uploading i'm late
i would like to but i'm not sure how to
upload anomaly maybe i can't because of
the x on it
all right there's going to be some kind
of alien out here is what you're telling
me i didn't know that
it doesn't look like a can right now
unfortunately
it's another travel thingy
that whisper that is something
not my own boots scaring the crap out of
me again
okay yeah
yeah me too me too but me too
okay
military report identification code 924
d4 bismuth after arrival on site a small
scouting unit was formed to overlook the
nearby territory the unit has returned
back after two hours bringing back an
item of unknown nature the unit didn't
encounter any hostile contacts but all
men have stated that at random point in
time they saw what seemed like a shadowy
figure moving among the trees
yikes available tools of identified
items of similar nature scattered across
the area a more equipped unit will be
sent to investigate after establishing a
permanent command center
item is secured and will be sent to the
main research subdivision soon that's my
military lady voice
all right
i'm not feeling great about it they're
doing a good job of building dread if
i'm being honest yeah give me those
yes please i love old pcp boards how did
you know
nothing
start fire
oh
i do need to do that i'm gonna need to
warm myself up any minute now
oh it's cold out here boy
you all got logs
any logs
yeah and this isn't just a survival
horror this is a survival survival
horror
i know
i hear you
oh god
oh it is really dark i also haven't
actually seen any means to get health
back or anything yet
that's me shivering okay i started to
freak out about the noise but it is my
own shivers
yeah we might die we might die
we freezing to death my friend okay
is there one in here
okay oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god
gotta go get warm
thank you the name is jordan
please
please
heed my
my frosted buns
oh
the headlight lamp has that's what the
battery is oh my okay
come on just more heat please give all
heat
and should i stop it
my thought was that maybe i could keep
some of the wood but i don't know if
that's right
oh man okay
i know
everybody calm down
okay
battery charger
what do i need that for though
oh you have a printer too huh
mega backpack that sounds nice
no no break down everything
no not these no oh my god
no we keeping those
okay what that's miles away
not even close
i'm now like feeling stressed about time
in a way that i wasn't before like i'm
like well
oh that looks like bullets
um
that because i can die and i have so few
resources again it's more survival than
i expected
did i not already search that i thought
so okay
and i don't think there's anything else
in here to search
oh the trash cans
yet
that is the other one right yeah to both
empty okay
um anything else for me to such
and this seems to me like there's gonna
be some kind of alien out there
the vibes are bad you guys the vibes are
real bad
that is freaking me out okay oh there's
so many ways to go i'm gonna go through
the middle because the lights here
oh jeez
i'm very sure that i'm going to die
which i don't love
i don't love that for me
but what is a survival game if you
aren't uh perpetually pooping your own
pants
dude my battery's so low
i could get lost out here
have you thought about that
i wonder if
keep going keep going keep going it's
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
clean pants at 3d printer that's a great
idea
shoot everything that moves is not a
terrible idea
why is that light green
oh okay okay
oh boy i am nervous um okay
i will take that thank you and those
thank you
it's also like a bit quiet right now
which is freaking me out
a tree it's fine
tickle
radio
tickle
fire barrel i don't have enough
uh i'm okay actually like i probably
will need to go back for that but i
don't think i need to just yet
we could get a little bit closer to
death
right i'm gonna go scope this out
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god
it is just nothing
no it's not
i can see myself getting lost dude
it's a whole house okay okay
okay if you could just hang out there
that would actually be very comforting
is he like a zombie
dude
are you invincible
oh no
okay please tell me that was only one of
them
okay
um
i'm where i'm freezing to death
so my guess
oh god i'm gonna die again
[Music]
exoskeleton
[Music]
wires
uh i ain't got no wood
so different areas have different things
is what that seems to be telling me
jesus do you have any wood
the battery's going to run out oh man
oh man oh boy oh heck
heck and dang heck
uh what uh
why none of these people putting any
wood in their trash bins
all right we're gonna run down the hill
keep that off
see if if i oh god
if i can make it the whole way back to
to
the first camp before i die even though
i don't know if that will help like
maybe i could go home
yeah i'm seeing it
i think i can probably go home
and then come back
oh buddy i know you're cold
i'm i feel it i fee i'm feeling it
i'm sensing the cold
oh gosh
we're gonna go home
to our nice warm i think cabin
and then we'll come back shelter
i think this will work
so it looks like different um places
have different modules which is
interesting okay yes we are warm
thankfully
yeesh
it's stressful out there
yeah this is why we don't go outside
the moral of this game is don't go
outside and don't help anybody
clearly
yeah bottom left bars body heat
mid left is my
battery obviously uh health obviously
bottom right is battery which is
dead
i wonder if maybe
i can up it somehow
no
i maybe would have to make another one i
don't actually know probably would have
to make another one
that's a lot
it's not happening
charger in the house we didn't see
you're right maybe i can charge it
somehow
i can't see any means to his old
um
maybe i could charge it at the
at the
the the
you know the at the you know what you
know what i'm saying
you can
okay
so this is potentially what i have to do
is just make sure that i come back to
this excellent cart
pretty frequently
um and then we might be all right
i'm into this game i'm enjoying it
i love uh
survival management situations and this
is certainly heavy on that
i know
also is it light on
is it less dark out
maybe
am i
maybe
unsure
i think it looks lighter but i could be
completely wrong i'm really not positive
did i finish elden ring not even close
i do think i will
but uh no not even plus
not in any rush to do so
did restart though
um
yeah i don't know i get i want to
explore but like
girl you going freeze to death
you do not need to be exploring out here
all right hoping that this man that i
killed is not capable of respawning
and that maybe he left something behind
like it seems like there was some kind
of alien situation that has zombified
the soldiers or whatever
he didn't leave anything behind
no he didn't
and he's not there
what
it was right there the whole time
all right
keep
nuven
well maybe that's all there was to find
here
seems fairly likely that that is all
that there was to find
oh
okay
i didn't think that would work
it's just taking me back
yeah okay
so
uh i can keep going forward from here
i feel better now that we have battery
and wood though
things are feeling
safer
i haven't been here have i
i have
this just looks different to how i
remember seeing it
okay
i don't know i definitely want to know
well the blizzard's gonna cause some
issues for me personally i'd prefer if
you
chilled out a little bit
i've been in a blizzard before it was
physically painful
like
it hurt
those two things are synonymous
you like slap your face about
i'm not loving the low visibility at all
though
okay
location added to math
oh this is too big
this is too big you can't be this you
can't be this large
who do you think you are
it might be fine it might be fine
it kind of looks like it's nighttime
again
okay
yeah when it's really windy sand blast
in your face yes
it was an actual blizzard though it was
in alaska
i think i'm just gonna leave it on
because stopping the fire last time i
don't think made me keep the wood
i'm not sure
yeah i'll pick it up thank you
yeah give me all that it's all good
stuff
okay anything here
that's okay just bullets
you are giving me a lot of bullets i'm
expecting
some combat
okay
keep moving
more wood thank you
these are all searchable battery charger
i just don't feel like i need to search
right now oh well charge right now is
all
i'm gonna turn the fire up just
in case i don't know if i should do that
i'm not sure
um
connect charger
yeah i didn't
i guess they just are everywhere um okay
let's give you
a bunch of stuff
oh that's just a
well okay i'm in the wrong menu i get it
gaskets
capacitor
metal
amplifier
um okay what what do you got for me
gas mask
and insulation
can i do both
no
what does it do
seems like the right call
it's a suit
maybe gives me more
resistance i'm thinking
so i won't take as much uh
cold
damage as it were
the gas mask i wonder
if slash what i need it for
hmm
am i going to be streaming more in the
future
um great question nightlife i do not
intend for today to be my last stream no
wait wait wait wait do we have two guns
or is it just equipped to both
um okay and then we're gonna put the
battery in the battery slot
i can't equip the item suit battery
okay
okay interesting
i don't know what the dimensions of the
suit are but yeah still assuming the
same
i feel like we made some good progress
here
um how are we on the map
workshop keep going keep following the
path
welcome malco this
is
uh
expedition zero
it is a
survival horror
so far we're getting a lot heavier into
the survival parts than the horror parts
i would say
um oh it was on the whole time
it's dark again son of a
um but i'm enjoying it uh we basically
had a guy
offered to help us like get out of the
area i think
in exchange for finding some samples
of some kind of creature
that
okay
that supposedly killed all of the
soldiers who were in this area
that is where we're up to narratively
right now
scares me every time we did shoot a
single zombie
fallout vibes is fair i could see that
oh church
oh well that can't be good
video game church has ever been a good
place never
oh god
but if you were an alien would you hang
out in a church probably not right
they're ghosts
are they gonna attack me
famous last words
what
i kind of feel like i want to find out
like i want to find out
i don't know if i'll lose progress
my friends
maybe we just leave him to it
for now and then i'll go scope it out
wow i was not expecting that
oh my god
are you
hey hi there
hello
is he looking at me
why are you up here
you're pointing
you're yelling at somebody
okay again just assuming
we're cool
i think
now you're pointing at me that's that's
fine
i have no beef with your kind
okay
okay okay maybe what maybe maybe we'd be
chilling maybe we'd be cool
oh what is this
fallen
hate fallen
oh
because i put the painting back up
wow this i did not expect this to be a
part of this game
and that is interesting
it what did it do it turned lights on i
think
okay
hello
good friends of mine
this is cool man um should i
yeah
just me and my my ghost buddies hanging
out we vibing
we having a good time
doing great
well it's a christian judge that is
jesus himself
okay
maybe it's like cabin in the woods world
there's just all sorts of [ __ ] going on
you might be right
um
yeah very creative okay everybody cool
everybody cool
everybody cool
something must move this looks like
there is a way down
uh jesus
can you help me out can you move that
for me
my lord
in this time of need
jesus came with anything
all right
anybody see any
zombies
zombies zammies
no
zombies
heat harness module
i'll give you what i can my friend
miles off
absolutely miles off i maybe like should
be rethinking the way i'm approaching
this too i'm just splitting up all of my
resources across every different one
that i find and it's
probably a bad idea
i should probably
be a little bit more selective about it
um
gaskets
wait that's pretty close actually
i might be able to make that work
what is this
something popped up on the ui there
didn't it
i assumed it was this little bit of hang
on no it's just
that's not much
lost longer in sub-zero temperatures
sounds great
hey
a quick question
anybody have any metal
do you reckon i can put some bullets in
i can
all right
it's ai huh
and then we're just gonna take them back
out
okay that seems handy
and i will take that split wood thank
you
all right we're making progress we're
making progress
um
you guys you good everybody
everybody good i'm gonna walk through
one i'm gonna take the risk i'm gonna
take the risk
that was cool okay i guess that's all
that happened
and i'm gonna start leaving the fires on
i think
okay
um okay down from the church
and onward
give myself a nice charge
beautiful oops
onward we go god that's so far away
uh
it's goddamn dark out again
oh thank you
henry doc thank you so much
right
keep moving
going the right way yep
oh it's so dark
it's so dark
and i guess this game is confirmed for
me now that i do not know what to expect
this feels like a circle it's not okay
okay okay okay okay
i found that zombie last time because it
made noise so i'm just kind of assuming
that oh nothing
um
that i'll be able to heal one again if
it shows up
pick up the split wood pick up the split
wood
i don't need the stove right now we
could do that that's fine with me
take a nice nap
there's john smith in here
hello john welcome we're playing a game
right now called expedition zero
and i'm enjoying it
um
okay
yeah i could always go back home
i'm good i don't need to i'm fine
this is a big map and this is just like
one of several maps
hmm there's a pathway up this way and a
pathway through
i'm gonna go with the through path i
wanna uncover like the whole bottom
right now
that's what i'm thinking
okay
i do really enjoy survival games
it just like makes you have to think all
the time in a way that
a lot of other games don't i think
okay nothing
i'll take that
damn you
this is another battery
i feel like i need two of them but i
guess empty can
damn there's loads of stuff out here
is that an outhouse
all right
medium project case
i love those how did you know
okay it looks like it's light out again
which we love is that a bathtub i don't
trust that for a second
scrape out the outhouse no zombies no
zombies no zombies
can you imagine if they put a jump scare
in there can you imagine how rude that
would be
okay how about in here
just my own feet
people used to live out here
what you telling me
oh
you bought a frame that big for your dog
that's the cutest thing i've ever seen
oh
the headlights okay
i could go charge at the cot
and maybe heat up back home for a minute
before i keep going it seems like a good
call
let's do that go back home get some heat
charge my helmet before we
expedition onward
did i loot this
i did the voice acting for the um
the getting cold and the running out of
stamina is
very dramatic like in a good way it
actually is stressful
all right
we're gonna go home for a little bit
we're gonna go home for a little bit
we will
get
nice and
cozy for a minute
before we continue onward